let me pull the story we have from
timcast.com ohio introduces parental
rights and education bill takes aim at
promotion of divisive concepts in
schools so this was just from the other
day and it's similar to what we're
seeing with florida then we have this
story from texas tribune
critics of texas's push for a don't say
gay bill say acknowledging lgbtq people
isn't the same as teaching kids about
sex well hey i agree the only so the
issue here is uh that's not what what
the conservatives the right or you know
people who who were in favor of the
parental rights bill did they did that
they associated lgbtq with this bill
they said it's called don't say gay now
they're complaining that people think
they're linked
isn't that just funny it's like the the
point i've been making since the
beginning is that someone's like hey
don't talk to my kids about sex in
secret and they say you hate gay people
it's like
you created that connection and now
you're complaining about the connection
existing these people live in their own
ridiculous universe well and it's also
laughable too that they would think that
bringing that connection up or creating
it would deter people from opposing that
bill as if i'm supposed to say or
anyone's supposed to say who is a parent
you know i really don't want my child to
be groomed or have uncomfortable
conversations on sexuality on the other
hand it might hurt gay people's feelings
if we don't let that happen yeah the
extreme metaphor would be like if the
nazis put clown makeup on their face and
then did what they did you'd be like
well it's they're just joking because
they look like clowns like you can't
just say you're gay and then el devious
behavior is okay it doesn't matter what
your sexuality or how you claim what you
identify as doesn't matter a bunch of
clansmen wearing clown makeup being like
no no no it's not about racism it's
about clowns like yeah you just hate
clowns you just hate clowns
we're not buying it dude
it's it's a weird position
but the left keeps doing it i wonder if
it's actually working at this point
because you look at the polls man people
are just not having it parents
support the parental rights and
education bill because when you read it
when you read the summary when you read
the simple language it all makes sense
it's so interesting to me that the first
thing they say when you say this is not
good and we don't want groomies that you
hate gay people because it seems to me
like based on the chorus that we just
you know talked about and i was thinking
about that earlier i was like they
literally told us flat out they're
coming for our children i feel like
they're telling on themselves when
they're like well you hate gay people
because then they're like we're joking
yeah we're just trying to remember
lydia remember remember when those dudes
went around claiming that they were
nazis but then they're like yo it's
ironic
these people don't deserve the benefit
of the doubt okay
neither do the people who are claiming
to be ironic nazis either truth be told
yeah if you're gonna parody i mean i
think it should be it should say parody
on the thing before you load it up like
a twitter account you go to a profile it
says this is a parody account you can't
like have to sift through it to find out
after the fact was that a parody or
nothing
i got i gotta i i think this is good at
parody so i wanna know what you think
you have to accept the satirical posts
you make i know this because i post
ridiculous garbage all the time i
tweeted something like elon musk is on
the board the fashion i was like what if
he just lets all the fascists and nazis
back on twitter and then i put a crying
emoji yes i fully understand that some
people may see that tweet and think it's
real i don't care because it's not that
serious but if somebody wants to come
out make extreme statements like we're
coming for your children or that they're
nazis you better expect people to
believe you're being honest about what
that is people are going to believe your
jokes
they don't know who you are yeah so it's
a good question this this wheel convert
your children parody isn't a parody in
the proper sense because it's not as if
they're coming out and saying the
opposite of what they actually want to
do right so if i do a cartoon with a
character named republican man who comes
out and goes i'm going to put cigarettes
and happy meals and get everyone's
children addicted to smoking for
corporate profits or something
ridiculous that's a parody that's
satirical because that's not something i
as a conservative would actually be
pushing for i'm making fun of the way
left-wing people portray conservatives
but what they're doing here is they're
in some sense trying to poke fun or
death or delegitimize this idea that
conservatives will say gay people will
try to groom or convert their children
but they do so by saying oh no we will
convert your children but they try to
use flowery language to describe that
conversion so they say well can we will
groom them or convert them into being
more tolerant or better people or more
accepting people when those are really
all just synonyms for what republicans
are talking about in the first place is
accepting sexual degeneracy or engaging
in it if if republicans actually were
putting some kind of addicted chemic
addictive chemical or advocating for it
in happy meals
then i think the the the distinction
there works better like conservatives
clearly aren't in favor of addictive
chemicals in food for children except
for high fructose which is why that
would be satisfied well but you're
you're talking about something a bit
more so
yeah but then
so so the issue here is conservatives
are like i think you're secretly
grooming my children and then they make
a video saying they're doing it it's
like okay exactly exactly accusing the
republicans okay i'm the villain you
think i am watch me be villainous now
like that's not a joke
this is something the left does all the
time they will for years resist the
accusations thrown at them by the right
only to come out and accept the
accusation in a cheeky manner so they'll
go yeah no we are trying to convert your
kids
but because they're doing it in a
quote-unquote self-aware way they see it
as clever or acceptable when they're
just telling us something that we
already knew like when biden said he was
obama's vice president a couple days ago
like obviously i think he's not just i
think he doesn't know he was just joking
right but that but he was the vice
president but he's making a statement
about it's kind of fact like obama's way
more likable and powerful than he is
it's true well we might maybe not on
paper today but i i don't i don't talk
about we see this in other ways though
too right you can't you can't try to
parody himself
people will look at these videos of
biden and then try and push them to the
most extreme interpretation i don't play
that game people are like look at this
video of biden being lost and i'm like
he was looking for someone specific like
he was supposed to bring someone up and
introduce him and he couldn't find him
and so when when biden's like i'm the
vice president everyone laughs i'm like
i don't care if he said that he was
making he used to be biting he used to
be obama's vice president now when he
says trinidad shabbat of pressure
battacaf care and next now wrestling i'm
like that should be mocked and
questioned for sure yeah my point is
that the left has a habit of denying
accusations that republicans throw at
them to come out and either pretend to
be cheeky or act as if they're bold by
acknowledging that it was true all along
even though they spent years denying it
so we see this with uh people like beta
or going yeah we're going to come after
your ar-15 yeah we're going to take your
guns or what was popular among the left
about five or six years ago which was
going yeah i'm a socialist i actually do
believe in that because for years and
years and years they've been denying it
but then at some point they come out and
they act like they're brave and bold and
original for acknowledging the
accusation that we have been throwing at
them for years right they've repeatedly
well it turns out the slopes are in fact
slippery yes
that's that's the key thing to realize
right they would be like oh that you're
just that's a slippery slope fallacy
actually like we should be at a point
where slippery slope is a default
assumption that accurately describes
reality and then you have to prove that
actually no this is one every every
almost every single argument patriot act
it's like it's a slippery slope to this
ah you're overreacting and now that then
you get ten years later that the the
indefinite detention provisions in the
nda do people really not think that in
ten years like
pedophilia will just be another sexual
orientation like in the world in the
world
all of the people who come out and favor
it too are going to act as if they're
either being cheeky or being bold in
this exact same way we see this non-stop
how long is it before some lefty writes
an article about how actually the
grooming that was being discussed all
along is in their view morally
legitimate and then act like they're
they're bold for saying so when we knew
the entire time that that's how they
felt i think in 10 years
this is the joke we've said the
republican party will be a bunch of you
know transgender communists and the left
will be metaverse
you know um
what's what's what's what's the hive
mind uh metaverse yeah we'll be trying
to hold the line on pedophilia bad in
ten years right we'll be fighting that's
that debate well republicans no i right
right but republicans are gradually just
giving in to whatever left wants exactly
well hopefully hopefully this is this is
how we stop it right like true true like
don't give up the brand it's ignorance
the bills are simple they're simple yeah
it's it's not like what the left is
doing with these nefarious tactics it's
like conservatives are just like uh we
want them we want to make sure parents
know what's going on and they're losing
their minds
the downside is they're responding to
the actions and they're not looking far
enough ahead to see what's coming to
prevent it which is the metaverse
grooming in the metaverse digital
grooming then you try to get haptic
feedback machines where you can actually
feel things on your body uh haptically
that's
incredibly disturbing to think about a
five-year-old with a haptic feedback
suit being groomed by some old man
on the internet and like so think about
that you got to start thinking ahead
guys if you're making legislation and
preparing and protecting from this stuff
well ban the internet just get rid of it
all everyone can use telephones i think
well i think you're right that in order
to fight against this one of the things
we absolutely have to do is refer to
this as grooming we need to continue to
use the proper language to discuss and
summarize these things but on top of
that it isn't just enough to use the
word we have to treat it as if it
actually is grooming if someone says i
don't support the don't say gay law and
then you explain what the law actually
is to them and after looking into it
doing the research and learning what it
means they're still against it stop
associating with that person they're
okay with grooming children i know we
talk a lot on the right about how we
shouldn't disassociate with people
because we disagree with our politics
but this is not disagreeing on politics
this is one group of people saying it
should be okay to sexually confuse and
groom children those are not the kinds
of people you want to associate with or
have in your life it there has to be a
social cost that a person pays for
supporting grooming i i understand i
don't know if ostracization is the key i
don't know you might be right there dude
look that's what i've been saying
there's two distinct universes here the
left knows exactly what they're doing
imagine there's two battleships in the
ocean and one of them is firing the
missiles and they're just coming
straight at the other and saying it's
getting bombed and then on on that ship
they're like now slow down we don't want
to we don't want to fight with the other
guys it's like dude at a certain point
you just say hey why don't we leave yeah
sometimes the fight is picked with you
and you don't get to change exactly and
as we say socialists don't have kids
they have yours exactly and this entire
you know conservative commitment to
never hurting anybody's feelings or
always being open-minded and tolerant
towards other perspectives including the
most absurd far less left perspectives
uh imaginable it doesn't really work
with a lot of issues especially issues
like this people have to stand up
against this this isn't just some
abstraction right they're actually
coming after children i am i am
genuinely convinced in 10 years
the republican party is going to be a
bunch of lgbtqia
because i i sit down and argue with
conservatives about the ahmedabary case
because they actually come in here and
they're like i believe that was all
justified that the guy who filmed it is
going to prison for the rest of his life
and i'm like why would he go to prison
and they're like well because they did
it and i'm like bro
if if people on the right are still
sending their kids to college people
with a straight face come in here come
on this show and they're like yeah i'm
sending my kids to college and i'm like
do you watch the show you're about to be
on
do you know what is happening in your
country why would you advocate for that
for your kids yeah they'll be fine
i guess that's the way everything goes
just tired of being parents for 18 years
and are looking forward to the break or
something yeah but the break is simple
hey you're 18. get a job move out but
get an apartment you don't got to go to
college to do that
but but this is the point when
when you when you have people on fox and
conservatives
saying
you know what i think it was so that
they didn't look racist with the kyle
rittenhouse thing they said well the
kyle rittenhouse thing proves that
justice is served and the almond arbory
thing proves that we all believe in true
justice no the right caved on the ahmed
arbory stuff because they don't want to
look racist because many republicans are
more worried about the opinion of the
new york times than their own
constituents and
whatever else is you know they're
worried about with with big media yes
which is why conservatives do not stand
up for their own values and which is why
we are in a situation where if you are
in favor of the grooming bill there are
zero social consequences but if you're
against it you could potentially lose
your job depending upon who your
employer is depending on whether they're
offended by that perspective people are
too afraid to speak out against the
abuse of children because they don't
want to lose their job
that's insane and the last time i was in
the show i was talking about this and i
was very pessimistic but i want to say
this if you're an audience member who's
watching this i believe in you i think
you have the opportunity to speak out
against this stuff you should and i
think you're going to do it i think the
people watching the show are going to
get fed up with this stuff as fed up
with it as we are and they're gonna be
bold about it and i really hope you are
it was a couple of years ago we were
talking about how you need to stand up
against the wokeness because they're
literally burning down cities people are
dying and we kept hearing people saying
yeah but i'll lose my job and i have
kids okay well now the issue is has
escalated the point where they're
grooming your kids in these public
schools
and people are like but i'll lose my job
and it's like okay dude look
if you are okay with your kids being at
these schools where you know they're
grooming them because you don't lose
your job then i i don't think i need to
advocate for any of this stuff to you
because you're not interested in
actually making things better i
understand life's hard but the crazy
thing to me is that people once got on a
boat for three months to come to a
barren shoreline and many of them died
just because they were like this i need
a better life for my kids and now people
are like
i i don't know what i would do if i lost
my job well like sheamus said there
there's there's other jobs out there
there's there's a path forward but more
importantly i guess maybe it's easy for
me to say i don't have kids and that's
that's that's what everyone says but uh
i've asked this question of everybody
would you rather have a job
and know that your kids spend eight
hours a day with a groomer or be
homeless with your kid not knowing where
your food's coming from and everyone
always says homeless with my kid not
knowing where my food is coming from
yeah so that's it right yeah yeah i mean
it's like but you know this is why we
need laws right like because ultimately
you know people need to be able to work
like part of like what we're all trying
to build on the right i assume is a
world again where you can people can
sustain a family on a single income
people can
like not necessarily like not
necessarily have to do child care and i
think one of the basic the basic
functions of public education especially
you know those early ages where you're
talking like five to ten is
child care like that's a basic function
that the state is performing um so that
people can go off to work and not have
to stay home with their kids let's let's
just i want to mention one more thing
all right um so i want to mention this
because on last show when we did talk
about this i said i was a little bit
black-pilled and i i was saying that
there are people who really will will
watch the show and think about these
ideas but they're too afraid to talk
about them and reading the comments
section it turns out there are a lot of
people who insist that they are talking
about these things in real life and at
their work and i just you know i really
want to commend them because i know
that's very difficult i know it's very
difficult to do and i genuinely have
faith in this audience that if you're
watching this and you don't usually talk
about this stuff you have to and i
really believe you can and will it sends
out shock waves when you communicate
concepts you see it reverberating
through our collective consciousness
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8pm
and we'll see you all there
you